The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Today, we're going
to talk about analyzing
task parallel algorithms--
multi-threaded algorithms.
And this is going
to rely on the fact
that everybody has taken
an algorithms class.
And so I want to remind
you of some of the stuff
you learned in your
algorithms class.
And if you don't
remember this, then it's
probably good to bone
up on it a little bit,
because it's going
to be essential.
And that is the topic of
divide-and-conquer recurrences.
Everybody remember divide
and conquer recurrences?
These are-- and there's a
general method for solving them
that will deal with most
of the ones we want,
called the Master Method.
And it deals with recurrences
in the form T of n
equals a times T of
n over b plus f of n.
And this is
generally interpreted
as I have a problem of size n.
I can solve it by solving a
problems of size n over b,
and it costs me f of n
work to do that division
and accumulate whatever
the results are of that
to make my final result.
For all these recurrences,
the unstated base case
is that this is a running time.
So T of n is constant
if n is small.
So does that makes sense?
Everybody familiar with this?
Right?
Well we're going to
review it anyway,
because I don't like to go ahead
and just assume, and then leave
20% of you or more, or less,
left behind in the woods.
So let's just remind
ourselves of what this means.
So it's easy to understand this
in terms of a recursion tree.
I start out, and the
idea is a recursion tree
is to take the
running time, here,
and to reexpress it
using the recurrence.
So if I reexpress
this and I've written
it a little bit differently,
then I have an f of n.
I can put an f of n
at the root, and have
a copies of T of n over b.
And that's exactly the same
amount of work as I had--
or running time as
I had in the T of n.
I've just simply expressed
it with the right hand side.
And then I do it
again at every level.
So I expand all the leaves.
I only expanded one here
because I ran out of space.
And you keep doing that
until you get down to T of 1.
And so then the trick of
looking at these recurrences
is to add across the rows.
So the first row
adds up to f of n.
The second row adds up
to a times f of n over b.
The third one is a squared f of
n over b squared, and so forth.
And the height here, now.
Since I'm taking n and
dividing it by b each time,
how many times can I divide
by b until I get to something
that's constant size?
That's just log base b of n.
So, so far, review--
any questions here?
For anybody?
OK.
So I get the height, and
then I look at how many--
if I've got T of 1
work at every leaf,
how many leaves are there?
And for this analysis we're
going to assume everything
works out--
n is a perfect power
of b and so forth.
So if I go down k levels,
how many sub problems
are there at k levels?
a of the k.
So how many levels
am I going down?
h, which is log base b of n.
So I end up with a to log
base b of n times what's
at the leaf, which is T of 1.
And T of 1 is constant.
a log base b of n--
that's the same as n
to the log base b of a.
OK.
That's just a little bit
of exponential algebra.
And you can-- one
way to see that is,
take the log of both
sides of both equations,
and you realize that
all that's used there
is the commutative law.
Because if you
take the log base--
if you take log of a log bn,
you get log bn times log--
if you take a base b, log ba.
And then you get the same thing
if you take the log base b
of what I have as
the result. Then you
get the exponent log base
ba times log base b of n.
So same thing, just
in different orders.
So that's just a little bit
of math, because this is--
basically, we're interested
in, what's the growth in n?
So we prefer not to have
log n's in the denominator.
We prefer to have n's--
sorry, in the exponent
we prefer to have n's.
So that's basically
the number of things.
And so then the question
is, how much work is there
if I add up all of these
guys all the way down there?
How much work is in
all those levels?
And it turns out
there's a trick,
and the trick is to compare n
to log base b of a with f of n.
And there are three cases that
are very commonly arising,
and for the most part, that's
what we're going to see,
is just these three cases.
So case 1 is the case where
n to the log base b of a
is much bigger than f of n.
And by much bigger, I mean it's
bigger by a polynomial amount.
In other words,
there's an epsilon such
that the ratio between the two
is at least n to the epsilon.
There's an epsilon
greater than 0.
In other words, f of n
is O of n to the log base
b of a minus epsilon
in the numerator
there, which is the
same as n log base b
of a divided by
n to the epsilon.
In that case, this is
geometrically increasing,
and so all the weight--
the constant fraction
of the weight--
is in the leaves.
So then the answer is T of n
is n to the log base b of a.
So if n to log base b of
a is bigger than f of n,
the answer is n
to the log base b
of a, as long as it's bigger
by a polynomial amount.
Now, case 2 is the situation
where n to the log base b of a
is approximately
equal to f of n.
They're very similar in growth.
And specifically, we're going
to look at the case where f of n
is n to the log base b of
a poly-logarithmic factor--
log to the k of n for some
constant k greater than
or equal to 0.
That greater than or equal
to 0 is very important.
You can't do this
for negative k.
Even though negative k is
defined and meaningful,
this is not the answer
when k is negative.
But if k is greater
than or equal to 0,
then it turns out
that what's happening
is it's growing arithmetically
from beginning to end.
And so when you solve
it, what happens is,
you essentially add
an extra log term.
So the answer is, if f
of n is n to the log base
b of a log to the k n, the
answer is n to the log base
b of a log to the k plus 1 of n.
So you kick in one extra log.
And basically, it's like--
on average, there's basically--
it's almost all equal,
and there are log layers.
That's not quite the math,
but it's good intuition
that they're almost all equal
and there are log layers,
so you tack on an extra log.
And then finally, case 3 is the
case when no to the log base
b is much less than f
of n, and specifically
where it is smaller by, once
again, a polynomial factor--
by an n to the epsilon factor
for epsilon greater than 0.
It's also the case
here that f has
to satisfy what's called
a regularity condition.
And this is a condition
that's satisfied
by all the functions we're
going to look at-- polynomials
and polynomials
times logarithms,
and things of that nature.
It's not satisfied
for weird functions
like sines and cosines
and things like that.
It's also not-- more
relevantly, it's
not satisfied if you have
things like exponentials.
So this is-- but for all the
things we're going to look at,
that's the case.
And in that case, things are
geometrically decreasing,
and so all the work
is at the root.
And the root is
basically cos f of n,
so the solution is theta f of n.
We're going to hand
out a cheat sheet.
So if you could conscript
some of the TAs to get that
distributed as
quickly as possible.
OK.
So let's do a
little puzzle here.
So here's the cheat sheet.
That's basically what's on it.
And we'll do a little
in-class quiz, self-quiz.
So we have T of n is
4T n over 2 plus n.
And the solution is?
This is a thing that,
as a computer scientist,
you just memorize this so that
you can-- in any situation,
you don't have to even
look at the cheat sheet.
You just know it.
It's one of these basic things
that all computer scientists
should know.
It's kind of like,
what's 2 to the 15th?
What is it?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
And interestingly,
that's my office number.
I'm in 32-G768.
I'm the only one in this data
center with a power of 2 office
number.
And that was totally unplanned.
So if you need to remember my
office number, 2 to the 15th.
OK, so what's the solution here?
AUDIENCE: Case 1.
CHARLES LEISERSON: It's case 1.
And what's the solution?
AUDIENCE: n squared?
CHARLES LEISERSON: n squared.
Very good.
Yeah.
So n to the log base b of a
is n to the log base 2 of 4.
Log base 2 of 4 is 2,
so that's n squared.
That's much bigger than n.
So it's case 1, and the
answer is theta n squared.
Pretty easy.
How about this one?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
It's n squared log n.
Once again, the first
part is the same.
n to the log base b
of a is n squared.
n squared is n squared
log to the 0 n.
So it's case 2 with k
equals 0, and so you just
tack on an extra log factor.
So it's n squared log n.
And then, of course,
we've got to do this one.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah, n
cubed, because once again,
n to log base b
of a is n squared.
That's much less than n
cubed. n cubed's bigger,
so that dominates.
So we have theta n squared.
What about this one?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Theta of n squared.
CHARLES LEISERSON: No.
That's not the answer.
Which case do you think it is?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Case 2?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK.
No.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: None of the cases?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
It's none of the cases.
It's a trick question.
Oh, I'm a nasty guy.
I'm a nasty guy.
This is one where the master
method does not apply.
This would be case
2, but k has to be
greater than or equal to
0, and here k is minus 1.
So case two doesn't apply.
And case 1 doesn't
apply, where we're
comparing n squared to
n squared over log n,
because the ratio there is
1 over log n, and that--
sorry, the ratio there is log n,
and log n is smaller than any n
to the epsilon.
And you need to have an n
to the epsilon separation.
There's actually a more--
the actual answer is n
squared log log n for that one,
by the way, which you can prove
by the substitution method.
And it uses the same idea.
You just do a little
bit different math.
There's a more general solution
to this kind of recurrence
called the Akra-Bazzi method.
But for most of what
we're going to see,
it's sufficient to just--
applying the Akra-Bazzi
method is more complicated
than simply doing the table
lookup of which is bigger
and if sufficiently big,
it's one or the other,
or the common case where they're
about the same within a log
factor.
So we're going to use
the master method,
but there are more
general ways of solving
these kinds of things.
OK.
Let's talk about some
multi-threaded algorithms.
First thing I want to
do is talk about loops,
because loops are a great
thing to analyze and understand
because so many
programs have loops.
Probably 90% or more of the
programs that are parallelized
are parallelized by
making parallel loops.
The spawn and sync
types of parallelism,
the subroutine-type
parallelism, is not
done that frequently in code.
Usually, it's loops.
So what we're going
to look at is a code
to do an in-place
matrix transpose,
as an example of this.
So if you look at
this code, I want
to swap the lower
side of the matrix
with the upper
side of the matrix,
and here's some
code to do it, where
I parallelize the outer loop.
So we're running the outer
index from i equals 1 to n.
I'm actually running the
indexes from 0 to n minus 1.
And then the inner loop
goes from 0 up to i minus 1.
Now, I've seen people
write transpose code--
this is one of these
trick questions
they give you in interviews,
where they say, write
the transpose of a
matrix with nested loops.
And what many people will
do is, the inner loop,
they'll run to n rather
than running to i.
And what happens if you
run the inner loop to n?
It's a very expensive
identity function.
And there's an
easier, faster way
to compute identity than with
doubly nested loops where
you swap everything and
you swap them all back.
So it's important that
the iteration space
here, what's the shape
of the iteration space?
If you look at
the i and j values
and you map them out on a plane,
what's the shape that you get?
It's not a square,
which it would
be if they were both going
from 1 to n, or 0 to n minus 1.
What's the shape of
this iteration space?
Yeah, it's a triangle.
It's basically-- we're
going to run through all
the things in this lower area.
That's the idea.
And we're going to swap it with
the things in the upper one.
But the iteration space
runs through just the lower
triangle-- or,
correspondingly, it
runs through the
upper triangle, if you
want to view it from
that point of view.
But it doesn't go
through both triangles,
because then you
will get an identity.
So anyway, that's just a tip
when you're interviewing.
Double-check that
they've got the loop
indices to be what
they ought to be.
And here what we've done
is, we've parallelized
the outer loop, which
means, how much work is
on each iteration of this loop?
How much time does it take to
execute each iteration of loop?
For a given value
of i, what does it
cost us to execute the loop?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
Theta i, which means that--
if you think about
this, if you've
got a certain number
of processors,
you don't want to just chunk it
up so that each processor gets
an equal range of i to work on.
You need something that's
going to load balance.
And this is where
the Cilk technology
is best, is when there are these
unbalanced things, because it
does the right
thing, as we'll see.
So let's talk a little bit
about how loops are actually
implemented by the Open Cilk
compiler and runtime system.
So what happens is, we have
this doubly-nested loop here,
but the only one that
we're interested in
is the outer loop, basically.
And what it does is, it
creates this recursive program
for the loop.
And what is this program doing?
I'm highlighting,
essentially, this part.
This is basically
the loop body here,
which has been lifted into
this recursive program.
And what it's doing is,
it is finding a midpoint
and then recursively
calling itself
on the two sides until it
gets down to, in this case,
a one-element iteration.
And then it executes the body
of the loop, which in this case
is itself a for loop, but
not a parallel for loop.
So it's doing
divide and conquer.
It's just basically
tree splitting.
So basically, it's got
this control on top of it.
And if I take a look at what's
going on in the control,
it looks something like this.
So this is using the DAG
model that we saw before.
And now what I have
here highlighted
is the lifted body of the loop--
sorry, of the control.
And then down below in the
purple, I have the lifted body.
And what it's doing
is basically saying,
let me divide it into two parts,
and then I spawn one recurrence
and I call the other.
And I just keep dividing
like that till I get down
to the base condition.
And then the work
that I'm doing--
I've sort of illustrated here--
the work I'm doing in
each iteration of the loop
is growing from 1 to n.
I'm showing it for 8, but in
general, this is working from 1
to n for this particular one.
Is that clear?
So that's what's
actually going on.
So the Open Cilk runtime system
does not have a loop primitive.
It doesn't have loops.
It only has, essentially, this
ability to spawn and so forth.
And so things, effectively,
are translated into this divide
and conquer, and
that's the way that you
need to think about loops when
you're thinking in parallel.
Make sense?
And so one of the questions is,
that seems like a lot of code
to write for a simple loop.
What do we pay for that?
How much did that cost us?
So let's analyze
this a little bit--
analyze parallel loops.
So as you know,
we analyze things
in terms of work and span.
So what is the work
of this computation?
Well, what's the work
before you get there?
What's the work of the
original computation--
the doubly-nested loop?
If you just think about
it in terms of loops,
if they were serial loops,
how much work would be there?
Doubly-nested loop.
In a loop, n iterations.
In your iteration,
you're doing i work.
Sum of i.
i equals 1 to n.
What do you get?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yes.
Theta n squared.
Doubly-nested group.
And although you're not
doing half the work,
you are doing the other
half of the work--
of the n squared work
that you might think
was there if you wrote the
unfortunate identity function.
So the question is,
how much work is
in this particular computation?
Because now I've got this whole
tree-spawning business going on
in addition to the work that
I'm doing in the leaves.
So the leaf work
here, along the bottom
here, that's all going to
be order n squared work,
because that's the same as
in the serial loop case.
How much does that other
stuff up top [INAUDIBLE]??
It looks huge.
It's bigger than the
other stuff, isn't it?
How much is there?
Basic computer science.
AUDIENCE: Theta of n?
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
It's theta of n.
Why is it theta if
n in the upper part?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: Because it's
geometrically decreasing
[INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
So going from the leaves to the
root, every level is halving,
so it's geometric.
So it's the total
number of leaves,
because there's constant work
in each of those phrases.
So the total amount
is theta n squared.
Another way of
thinking about this
is, you've got a complete
binary tree that we've
created with n leaves.
How many internal
nodes are there
in a complete binary
tree with n leaves?
In this case, there's
actually n over--
let's just say there's n leaves.
Yeah.
How many internal
nodes are there?
If I have n leaves, how many
internal nodes to the tree--
that is, nodes
that have children?
There's exactly n minus 1.
That's a property that's true
of any full binary tree--
that is, any binary tree
in which every non-leaf has
two children.
There's exactly n minus 1.
So nice tree properties, nice
computer science properties,
right?
We like computer science.
That's why we're here--
not because we're going
to make a lot of money.
OK.
Let's look at the span of this.
Hmm.
What's the span of
this calculation?
Because that's how we
understand parallelism,
is by understanding
work and span.
I see some familiar hands.
OK.
AUDIENCE: Theta n.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Theta n.
Yeah.
How did you get that?
AUDIENCE: The largest path
would be the [INAUDIBLE] node
is size theta n and [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
So we're basically--
the longest path
is basically going from
here down, down, down to 8,
and then back up.
And so the eight is really
n in the general case.
That's really n in
the general case.
And so we basically
are going down,
And so the span of the
loop control is log n.
And that's the
key takeaway here.
The span of loop
control is log n.
When I do divide and
conquer like that,
if I had an infinite
number of processors,
I could get it all done
in logarithmic time.
But the 8 there is linear.
That's order n.
In this case, n is 8.
So that's order n.
So then it's log
n plus order log
n, which is therefore order n.
So what's the parallelism here?
AUDIENCE: Theta n.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Theta n.
It's the ratio of the two.
The ratio of the two is theta n.
Is that good?
AUDIENCE: Theta of n squared?
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Well, parallelism of n
squared, do you mean?
Or-- is this good parallelism?
Yeah, that's pretty good.
That's pretty good,
because typically, you're
going to be working on
systems that have maybe--
if you are working
on a big, big system,
you've got maybe 64 cores
or 128 cores or something.
That's pretty big.
Whereas this is saying,
if you're doing that,
you better have a
problem that's really big
that you're running it on.
And so typically,
n is way bigger
than the number of processors
for a problem like this.
Not always the case,
but here it is.
Any questions about this?
So we can use our
work and span analysis
to understand
that, hey, the work
overhead is a constant factor.
And We're going to talk more
about the overhead of work.
But basically, from an
asymptotic point of view,
our work is n squared just
like the original code,
and we have a fair
amount of parallelism.
We have order n parallelism.
How about if we make the inner
loop be parallel as well?
So rather than just
parallelize the outer loop,
we're also going to
parallelize the inner loop.
So how much work do we
have for this situation?
Hint-- all work questions are
trivial, or at least no harder
than they were
when you were doing
ordinary serial algorithms.
Maybe we can come up with a
trick question on the exam
where the work changes,
but almost always, the work
doesn't change.
So what's the work?
Yeah. n squared.
Parallelizing stuff
doesn't change the work.
What it hopefully does is reduce
the span of the calculation.
And by reducing the span,
we get big parallelism.
That's the idea.
Now, sometimes it's the case
when you parallelize stuff
that you add work, and
that's unfortunate,
because it means that
even if you end up
taking your parallel program
and running it on one processing
core, you're not going
to get any speedup.
It's going to be a
slowdown compared
to the original algorithm.
So we're actually
interested generally
in work-efficient
parallel algorithms, which
we'll talk more about later.
So generally, we're
after work efficiency.
OK.
What's the span of this?
AUDIENCE: Is it theta n still?
CHARLES LEISERSON: It
is not still theta n.
What was your thinking
to say it was theta of n?
AUDIENCE: So the path would
be similar to 8, and then--
CHARLES LEISERSON:
But now notice
that 8 is a for loop itself.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I'm saying maybe you
could extend the path
another n so it would be 2n.
CHARLES LEISERSON: OK.
Not quite, but-- so
this man is commendable.
[APPLAUSE]
Absolutely.
This is commendable,
because this
is-- this is why I try to have
a bit of a Socratic method
in here, where I'm asking
questions as opposed to just
sitting here lecturing and
having it go over your heads.
You have the opportunity
to ask questions,
and to have your particular
misunderstandings or whatever
corrected.
That's how you learn.
And so I'm really in
favor of anybody who
wants to come here and learn.
That's my desire,
and that's my job,
is to teach people
who want to learn.
So I hope that this is a
safe space for you folks
to be willing to put
yourself out there and not
necessarily get stuff right.
I can't tell you how many
times I've screwed up,
and it's only by
airing it and so forth
and having somebody say,
no, I don't think it's
like that, Charles.
This is like this.
And I said, oh
yeah, you're right.
God, that was stupid.
But the fact is that
I no longer beat
my head when I'm being stupid.
Our natural state is stupidity.
We have to work hard
not to be stupid.
Right?
It's hard work not to be stupid.
Yeah, question.
AUDIENCE: It's not
really a question.
My philosophy on
talking in mid-lecture
is that I don't want to
waste other people's time.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Yeah, but usually when--
my experience is-- and this
is, let me tell you from--
I've been at MIT
almost 38 years.
My experience is that one
person has a question,
there's all these other
people in the room
who have the same question.
And by you
articulating it, you're
actually helping them out.
If I think you're going to slow,
if things are going too slow,
that we're wasting
people's time,
that's my job as the lecturer to
make sure that doesn't happen.
And I'll say, let's
take this offline.
We can talk after class.
But I appreciate
your point of view,
because that's considerate.
But actually, it's
more consideration
if you're willing to
air what you think
and have other people say, you
know, I had that same question.
Certainly there are going
to be people in the class
who, say, roll their
eyes or whatever.
But look, I don't
teach to the top 10%.
I try to teach to the top 90%.
And believe me--
[LAUGHTER]
Believe me that I get
farther with students
and have more people
enjoying the course
and learning this stuff--
which is not
necessarily easy stuff.
After the fact, you're going
to discover this is easy.
But while you're learning
it, it's not easy.
This is what Steven Pinker
calls the curse of knowledge.
Once you know something,
you have a really hard time
putting yourself in
the position of what
it was like to not know it.
And so it's very easy
to learn something,
and then when somebody
doesn't understand,
it's like, oh, whatever.
But the fact of the matter
is that most of us--
it's that empathy.
That's what makes for you
to be a good communicator.
And all of you I know
are at some point
going to have to
do communication
with other people who
are not as technically
sophisticated as you folks are.
And so this is really
good to sort of appreciate
how important it is to
recognize that this stuff isn't
necessarily easy when
you're learning it.
Later, you can learn it,
and then it'll be easy.
But that doesn't mean it's
not so easy for somebody else.
So those of you who think that
some of these answers are like,
come on, move along,
move along, please
be patient with the other
people in the class.
If they learn
better, they're going
to be better teammates
on projects and so forth.
And we'll all learn.
Nobody's in competition
with anybody here,
for grades or anything.
Nobody's in competition.
We all set it up so we're
going against benchmarks and so
forth.
You're not in competition.
So we want to make this
something where everybody
helps everybody learn.
I probably spent too much time
on that, but in some sense,
not nearly enough.
OK.
So the span is not order n.
We got that much.
Who else would
like to hazard to--
OK.
AUDIENCE: Is it log n?
CHARLES LEISERSON: It is log n.
What's your reasoning?
AUDIENCE: It's the normal
log n from the time before,
but since we're
expanding the n--
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yup.
AUDIENCE: --again into another
tree, it's log n plus log n.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
Log n plus log n.
Good.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: And
then what about the leaves?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: What's--
you got to add in the span
of the leaves.
That was just the
span of the control.
AUDIENCE: The leaves are just 1.
CHARLES LEISERSON:
The leaves are just 1.
Boom.
So the span of the outer
loop is order log n.
The inner loop is order log n.
And the span of the
body is order 1,
because we're going
down to the body,
now it's just doing one
iteration of serial execution.
It's not doing i iterations.
It's only doing one iteration.
And so I add all that
together, and I get log n.
Does that makes sense?
So the parallelism is?
This one, I should--
every hand in the room
should be up, waving to
call on me, call on me.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
n squared over log n.
That's the ratio of the two.
Good.
Any questions about that?
OK.
So the parallelism is
n squared over log n,
and this is more parallel
than the previous one.
But it turns out--
you've got to remember, even
though it's more parallel,
is it a better
algorithm in practice?
Not necessarily,
because parallelism
is like a thresholding thing.
What you need is enough
parallelism beyond the number
of processors that you have--
the parallel
slackness, remember?
So you have to have the number--
the amount of parallelism,
if it's much greater than
the number of processors,
you're good.
So for something like this,
if with order n parallelism
you're way bigger than
the number of processors,
you don't need to
parallelize the inner loop.
You don't need to
You'll be fine.
And in fact, we're talking a
little bit about overheads,
and I'm going to do
that with an example
from using vector addition.
So here's a really
simple piece of code.
It's a vector-- add two
vectors together, two arrays.
And all it does is,
it adds b into a.
You can see every
position as b into a.
And I'm going to
parallelize this
by putting a Cilk for in front,
rather than an ordinary for.
And what that does is,
it gives us this divide
and conquer tree once
again, with n leaves.
And the work here is
order n, because that's--
we've got n iterations
of constant time.
And the span is
just the control--
log n.
And so the parallelism
is n over log n.
So this is basically easier
than what we just did.
So now-- if I look at
this, though, the work
here includes some
substantial overhead,
because there are all
these function calls.
It may be order n,
and that's good enough
if you're certain
kinds of theoreticians.
This kind of theoretician,
that's not good enough.
I want to understand where
these overheads are going.
So the first thing
that I might do
to get rid of that overhead--
so in this case,
what I'm saying is
that as I do the
divide and conquer,
if I go all the way
down to n equals 1,
what am I doing in a leaf?
How much work is in one
of these leaves here?
It's an add.
It's two memory fetches and
a memory store and an add.
The memory operations are going
to be the most expensive thing
there.
That's all that's going on.
And yet, right before then,
I've done a subroutine call--
a parallel subroutine
call, mind you--
and that's going to have
substantial overhead.
And so the question is, do
you do a subroutine call
to add two numbers together?
That's pretty expensive.
So let's take a look at
how we can optimize away
some of this overhead.
And so this gets more into
the realm of engineering.
So the Open Cilk
system has a pragma.
Pragma is a compiler directive--
suggestion to the compiler--
where it can suggest, in this
case, that there be a grain
size up here of G, for
whatever you set G to.
And the grain size
is essentially--
we're going to use--
and it shows up
here in the code--
as instead of
ending up-- it used
to be high greater than
low plus 1, so that you
ended with a single element.
Now it's going to be plus
G, so that at the leaves,
I'm going to have up
to G elements per chunk
that I do when I'm doing
my divide and conquer.
So therefore, I can take
my subroutine overhead
and amortize it
across G iterations
rather than amortizing
across one iteration.
So that's coarsening.
Now, if the grain size
pragma is not specified,
the Cilk runtime system
makes its best guess
to minimize the overhead.
So what it actually
does at runtime is,
it figures out for the loop
how many cores it's running on,
and makes a good guess
as to the actual--
how much to run
serially at the leaves
and how much to do in parallel.
Does that make sense?
So it's basically
trying to overcome that.
So let's analyze
this a little bit.
Let's let i be the time for
one iteration of the loop body.
So this is i for iteration.
This is of this
particular loop body--
so basically, the cost
of those three memory
operations plus an add.
And G is the grain size.
And now let's take a
look-- add another variable
here, which is the time to
perform a spawn and return.
I'm going to call
a spawn and return.
It's basically the
overhead for spawning.
So if I look at the
work in this context,
I can view it as I've
got T1 work, which
is n here times the
number of iterations--
because I've got one, two,
three, up to n iterations.
And then I have--
and those are just
the normal iterations.
And then, since I have n over
G minus 1-- there's n over G
leaves here of
size G. So I have n
over G minus 1
internal nodes, which
are my subroutine overhead.
That's S. So the total work
is n times i plus n over G
minus 1 times S.
Now, in the original code,
effectively, the work is what?
If I had the code
without the Cilk
for loop, how much work is
there before I put in all
this parallel control stuff?
What would the work be?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: n i?
CHARLES LEISERSON: n times i.
We're just doing n iterations.
Yeah, there's a little
bit of loop control,
but that loop control
is really cheap.
And on a modern
out-of-order processor,
the cost of
incrementing a variable
and testing against its bound
is dwarfed by the stuff going on
inside the loop.
So it's ni.
So this part here--
oops, what did I do?
Oops, I went back.
I see.
So this part here--
this part here, there we go--
is all overhead.
This is what it
costs-- this part here
is what cost me originally.
So let's take a look
at the span of this.
So the span is
going to be, well,
if I add up what's at the
leaves, that's just G times i.
And now I've got
the overhead here
for any of these paths, which
is basically proportional--
I'm ignoring constants
here to make it easier--
log of n over G times S,
because it's going log levels.
And I've got n over G
chunks, because each--
I've got G things at the
iterations of each leaf,
so therefore the number
of leaves n over G.
And I've got n
minus 1 of those--
sorry, got log n of
those-- actually, 2 log n.
2 log n over G of those times
S. Actually, maybe I don't.
Maybe I just have
log n, because I'm
going to count it going
down and going up.
So actually, constant
of 1 is fine.
Who's confused?
OK.
Let's ask some questions.
You have a question?
I know you're confused.
Believe me, I spend--
one of my great
successes in life
was discovering that, oh,
confusion is how I usually am.
And then it's getting
confused that is--
that's the thing, because
I see so many people going
through life thinking
they're not confused,
but you know what,
they're confused.
And that's a worse
state of affairs
to be in than knowing
that you're confused.
Let's ask some questions.
People who are confused,
let's ask some questions,
because I want to make sure
that everybody gets this.
And for those who you think
know it already, sometimes
it helps them to know it
a little bit even better
when we go through a
discussion like this.
So somebody ask me a question.
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Could you explain the
second half of that [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
OK.
The second half
of the work part.
OK.
So the second half of the
work part, n over G minus 1.
So the first thing is,
if I've got G iterations
at the leaves of a binary
tree, how many leaves
do I have if I've got a
total of n iterations?
AUDIENCE: Is it n over G?
CHARLES LEISERSON: n over
G. That's the first thing.
The second thing is a
fact about binary trees--
of any full binary tree, but
in particular complete binary
trees.
How many internal
nodes are there
in a complete binary tree?
If n is the number of
leaves, it's n minus 1.
Here, the number of
leaves is n over G,
so it's n over G minus 1.
That clear up something
for some people?
OK, good.
So that's where that--
and now each of those,
I've got to do those three
colorful operations, which
is what I'm calling S.
So you got the work down?
OK.
Who has a question about span?
Span's my favorite.
Work is good right.
Work is more important,
actually, in most contexts.
But span is so cool.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: What did you mean
when you said [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: So
what I was saying-- well,
I think what I was saying--
I think I was mis-saying
something, probably, there.
But the point is that
the span is basically
starting at the top here, and
taking any path down to a leaf
and then going back up.
And so if I look at
that, that's going
to be then log of
the number of leaves.
Well, the number of leaves,
as we agreed, was n over G.
And then each of
those is, at most,
S to do the subroutine calling
and so forth that's bookkeeping
that's in that node.
That make sense?
Still I didn't
answer the question?
Or--
AUDIENCE: Why is that the span?
Why shouldn't it be [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: It
could be any of the paths.
But take a look at all the
paths, go down, and back up.
There's no path that's
going down and around
and up and so forth.
This is a DAG.
So if you just look at the
directions of the arrows.
You got to follow the
You can't go down and up.
You're either going down,
or you've started back up.
So it's always going
to be, essentially,
down through a set of
subroutines and back up
through a set of subroutines.
Does that make sense?
And if you think about the
code, the recursive code, what's
happening when you do
divide and conquer?
If you were operating
with a stack,
how many things would get
stacked up and then unstacked?
So the path down and
back up would also
be logarithmic at most.
Does that makes sense?
So I don't have a--
if I had one subtree here,
for example, dependent on--
oops, that's not the mode
I want to be in-- so one
subtree here dependent
on another subtree,
then indeed, the
span would grow.
But the whole point is not to
have these two things-- to make
these two things
independent, so I
can run them at the same time.
So there's no dependency there.
We good?
OK.
So here I have the
work and the span.
I have two things
I want out of this.
Number one, I want
the work to be small.
I want work to be close
to the work of the n times
i, the work of the
ordinary serial algorithm.
And I want the span to be
small, so it's as parallel
as possible.
Those things are working
in opposite directions,
because if you look,
the dominant term
for G in the first
equation is dividing n.
So if I want the work to be
small, I want G to be what?
Big.
The dominant term
for G in the span
is the G multiplied by the i.
There is another term there,
but that's a lower-order term.
So if I want the span to be
small, I want G to be small.
They're going in
opposite directions.
So what we're interested
in is picking a--
finding a medium place.
We want G to be--
and in particular, if you
look at this, what I want
is G to be at least S over i.
Why?
If I make G be much
bigger than S over i--
so if G is bigger
than S over i--
then this term
multiplied by S ends up
being much less than this term.
You see that?
That's algebra.
So do you see that
if I make G be--
if G is much less
than S over i--
so get rid of the minus 1.
That doesn't matter.
So that's really n times S
over G, so therefore S over G,
that's basically
much smaller than i.
So I end up with something
where the result is
much smaller than n i.
Does that make sense?
OK.
How we doing on time?
I'm going to get
through everything
that I expect to get
through, despite my rant.
OK.
Does that make sense?
We want G to be much
greater than S over i.
Then the overhead is
going to be small,
because I'm going to do a
whole bunch of iterations that
are going to make it so that
that function call was just
like, eh, who cares?
That's the idea.
So that's the goal.
So let's take a look at--
let's see, what was the--
let me just see here.
Did I-- somehow I feel like
I have something out of order
here, because now I have
the other implementation.
Huh.
OK.
I think-- maybe that
is where I left it.
OK.
I think we come back to this.
Let me see.
I'm going to lecture on.
So here's another
implementation of the for loop
to add two vectors.
And what this is going
to use as a subroutine,
I have this operator
called v add,
which itself does just
a serial vector add.
And now what I'm going to do
is run through the loop here
and spawn off additions--
and the min there is just
for a boundary condition.
I'm going to spin off
things in groups of G.
So I spin off, do a vector
add of size G, go on vector
add of size G, vector add of
size G, jumping G each time.
So let's take a look at
the analysis of that.
So now what I've got is, I've
got G iterations, each of which
costs me i.
And this is the
DAG structure I've
got, because the
for loop here that
has the Cilk spawn
in it is going along,
and notice that the
Cilk spawn is in a loop.
And so it's basically going--
it's spawning off G iterations.
So it's spawning off
the vector add, which
is going to do G iterations--
because I'm giving basically G,
because the boundary case let's
not worry about.
And then spawn off G, spawn off
G, spawn off G, and so forth.
So what's the work of this?
Let's see.
Well, let's make things
easy to begin with.
Let's assume G is
1 and analyze it.
And this is a common
thing, by the way,
is you as assume
that grain size is 1
and analyze it, and then
as a practical matter,
coarsen it to make
it more efficient.
So if G is 1, what's
the work of this?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
It was order n, because those
other two things are constant.
So exactly right.
It's order n.
In fact, this is a
technique, by the way,
that's called strip
mining, if you take away
the parallel thing, where
you take a loop of length n.
And you really have
nested loops here--
one that has n over G iterations
and one that has G iterations--
and you're going through
exactly the same stuff.
And that's the same as
going through n iterations.
But you're replacing
a singly-nested loop
by a doubly-nested loop.
And the only difference here
is that in the inner loop,
I'm actually spawning off work.
So here, the work is order
n, because I basically--
if I'm spinning off
just-- if G is 1,
then I'm spinning off
one piece of work,
and I'm going to n minus
1, spinning off one.
So I've got order
n work up here,
and order n work down below.
What's the span for this.
After all, I got in
spans there now--
sorry, n spawns, not n spans.
n spawns.
What's the span going to be?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Sorry?
Sorry I, couldn't hear--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Theta S?
No, it's bigger than that.
Yeah, you'd think,
gee, I just have to do
one thing to go down and up.
But the span is the longest
path in the whole DAG.
It's the longest path
in the whole DAG.
Where's the longest path
in the whole DAG start?
Upper left, right?
And where does it end?
Upper right.
How long is that path?
What's the longest one?
It's going to go all the way
down the backbone of the top
there, and then flip
down and back up.
So how many things are in the--
if G is 1, how many things
are my spawning off there?
n things, so the span is?
Order n?
So order n.
It's long.
So what's the parallelism here?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
It's order 1.
And what do we call that?
AUDIENCE: Bad.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Bad.
Right.
But there's a more
technical name.
They call that puny.
[LAUGHTER]
It's like, we went
through all this work,
spawned off all that stuff,
added all this overhead,
and it didn't go any faster.
I can't tell you
how many times I've
seen people do this when they
start parallel programming.
Oh, but I spawned
off all this stuff!
Yeah, but you didn't
reduce the span.
Let's now-- that was the
analyze it in terms of n--
sorry, in terms of G equals 1.
Now let's increase
the grain size
and analyze it in terms
of G. So once again,
what's the work now?
Work is always a gimme.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Same as before, n.
CHARLES LEISERSON: n.
Same as before. n.
The work doesn't change when you
parallelize things differently
and stuff like that.
I'm doing order n iterations.
Oh, but what's the span?
This is a tricky one.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: n over G.
CHARLES LEISERSON: Close.
That's half right.
Good.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON:
n over G plus G.
Don't forget that other term.
So the path that we care
about goes along the top
here, and then goes down there.
And this has span G.
So we've got n over G
here, because I'm doing
chunks of G, plus G.
So it's G plus n over
G. And now, how can I
choose G to minimize the span?
There's nothing to choose
to minimize the work,
except there's
some work overhead
that we're trying to do.
But how can I choose G
to minimize the span?
What's the best
value for G here?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: You got it.
Square root of n.
So one of these is increasing.
If G is increasing, n
over G is decreasing,
where do they cross?
When they're equal.
That's when G equals n over
G, or G is square root of n.
So this actually has decent--
n big enough, square root
of n, that's not bad.
So it is OK to spawn
things off in chunks.
Just don't make the
chunks real little.
What's the parallelism?
Once again, this
is always a gimme.
It's the ratio.
So square root of n.
Quiz on parallel loops.
I'm going to let you
folks do this offline.
Here's the answers.
If you quickly
write it down, you
don't have to think about it.
[RAPID BREATHING]
OK.
[LAUGHTER]
So take a look at
the notes afterwards,
and you can try to figure
out why those things are so.
So there's some performance
tips that make sense when
you're programming with loops.
One is, minimize the span
to maximize the parallelism,
because the span's
in the denominator.
And generally, you
want to generate
10 times more parallelism
than processors
if you want near-perfect
linear speed-up.
So if you have a lot more
parallelism than the number
of processors-- we talked
about that last time--
you get good speed-up.
If you have plenty
of parallelism,
try to trade some of it off
to reduce the work overhead.
So the idea was, for
any of these things,
you can fiddle with the
numbers, the grain size
in particular, to reduce--
it reduces the parallelism, but
it also reduces the overhead.
And as long as you've got
sufficient parallelism,
your code is going to
run just fine parallel.
It's only when you're
in the place where,
ooh, don't have
enough parallelism,
and I don't want to
pay the overhead.
Those are the sticky ones.
But most of the time, you're
going to be in the case
where you've got way
more parallelism than you
need, and the question is,
how can you reduce some of it
in order to reduced
the work overhead?
Generally, you should use
divide and conquer recursion
or parallel loops, rather
than spawning one small thing
after another.
So it's better to
do the Cilk for,
which already is doing divide
and conquer parallelism,
than doing the spawn
off one thing at a time
type of strategy, unless
you can chunk them
so that you have
relatively few things
that you're spawning off.
This would be fine.
The thing I say not-- this
would be fine if foo of i
was really expensive.
Fine, then we'll have
lots of parallelism,
because there's a
lot of work there.
But generally, it's better
to do the divide and conquer.
Generally, you should
make sure that the work
that you're doing per number of
spawns is sufficiently large.
So the spawns say,
well, how much
are you busting your work
into in terms of chunks?
Because the spawn has an
overhead, and so the question
is, well, how big is that?
And so you can coarsen
by using function calls
and in-lining near the leaves.
Generally better to parallelize
outer loops as opposed
to inner loops, if
you're forced to make
a choice, because
the inner loops,
they're the overhead you're
incurring every single time.
The outer loop,
you can amortize it
against the work
that's going on inside
that doesn't have the overhead.
And watch out for
scheduling overhead.
So here's an example of two
codes that have parallelism 2,
and one of them is
an efficient code,
and the other one is lousy code.
The top one is
efficient, because I
have two iterations that I run
in parallel, and each of them
does a lot of work.
There's only one scheduling
operation that happens.
The bottom one, I
have n iterations,
and each iteration
does work, too,
so I basically have n
iterations with overhead.
And so if you just look at
these, look at the overhead,
you can see what
the difference is.
OK.
I want to talk a little
bit about actually,
I have a whole
bunch of things here
that I'm not going
to get to, but I
didn't expect to get to them.
But I do want to get to some
of matrix multiplication.
People familiar
with this problem?
OK.
We're going to
assume for simplicity
that n is a power of 2.
So here's the typical way
of parallelizing matrix
multiplication.
I take the two outer loops
and I parallelize them.
I can't easily parallelize the
inner loop, because if I do,
I get a race
condition, because I'll
have two iterations that are
both trying to update C of i,
j.
So I can't just
parallelize k, so I'm just
going to parallelize i and j.
The work for this is what?
Triply-nested loop.
n cubed.
Everybody knows--
matrix multiplication,
unless you do something
clever like Strassen,
or one of the more recent--
Virgie Williams
algorithm-- you know
that the running time for the
standard algorithm is n cubed.
The span for this is what?
Yeah.
That inner loop is linear size,
and then you've got two log
n's--
log n plus log n plus n--
so it's order n.
So the parallelism
is around n squared.
If I ignore
constants, and I said
I was working on matrices of,
say, 1,000 by 1,000 or so,
the parallelism is
something like n squared,
which is about--
1,000 squared is a million.
Wow.
That's a lot of parallelism.
How many processors
are you running on?
Is it bigger than 10 times
the number of processors?
By a little bit.
Now, there's another
strategy that one
can use, which is
divide and conquer,
and this is the strategy
that's used in Strassen.
We're not going to do
the Strassen's algorithm.
We're just going to use the
eight multiply version of this.
For people who know
Strassen, more power to you.
It's a great algorithm.
Really surprising,
really amazing.
And it's actually worthwhile
doing in practice, by the way,
for sufficiently large matrices.
So the idea here is, I can
multiply two n by n matrices
by doing eight
multiplications of n over 2
by n over 2 matrices, and
then add two n by n matrices.
So when we start
talking matrices--
this is a little bit of a
diversion from the algorithms,
but it's so important, because
representation of matrices
is one of the things that
gets people into trouble when
they're doing any kind of
two-dimensional coding stuff.
And so I want to talk a
little bit about index,
and we're going to talk
about this more later when
we do cache behavior and such.
So how do you
represent sub-matrices?
The standard way of
representing those either
in row-major or
column-major order,
depending upon the
language you use.
Fortran uses
column-major ordering,
so there are a
lot of subroutines
that are column-major.
But for the most part, C, which
we're using, is row-major.
And so the question
is, if I take
a sub-matrix of a
large matrix, how
do I calculate where the i,
j element of that matrix is?
Here I have the
i, j element here.
I've got a matrix M,
which is embedded.
And by row major,
remember, that means
I just take row after row, and
I just put them in linear order
through the memory.
So every two-dimensional
matrix, you can index
as a one-dimensional matrix,
because all you have to do is--
which is exactly what
the code is doing--
you need to know the
beginning of the matrix.
But if you have a sub-matrix,
it's a little more complicated.
So here's the idea.
Suppose that you have
a sub-matrix m-- so
starting in location m
of this outer matrix.
Here we have the outer matrix,
which has length n sub M.
This is the big matrix--
actually I should
have called that m.
I should not have called
this n instead of m.
I should have called it
m sub something else,
because this is my m that
I'm interested in, which
is this location here.
And what I'm interested
in doing is finding out--
I named these
variables stupidly--
is finding out, where
is the i, j-th element
of this sub-matrix M?
If I tell you the beginning,
what do I add to get to i, j?
And the answer is that I've
got to add the number of rows
that comes down here.
Well, that's i times the
width of the full matrix
that you're taking it
out of, not the width
of your local sub-matrix.
And then you have
to add in the--
and then you add in
j from that point.
There we go.
OK.
So I have to add in the
length of the long matrix
plus j for each row i.
Does that make sense?
Because it's embedded in there.
You have to skip over full
rows of the outer matrix.
So you can't generally
just pass a sub-matrix
and expect to do indexing
on that when it's
embedded in a large matrix.
If you make a copy,
sure, then you
can index it according to
whatever the new copy is.
But if you want to operate
in place on matrices, which
is often the case, then you have
to understand that every row,
you have to jump a row
of the outer matrix, not
a row of whatever your
sub-matrix is, when you're
doing the divide and conquer.
So when we look at doing
divide and conquer--
I have a matrix here
which I want to now
divide into four sub-matrices
of size M over 2.
And the question is,
where's the starting corners
of each of those matrices?
So M 0, 0, that starts at the
same place as M. That upper
left one.
Where does M 0, 1 start?
Where's M 0, 1 start?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
CHARLES LEISERSON: Yeah.
M plus n over 2.
Where does M 1, 0 start?
This is the tricky one.
Here's the answer.
M plus the long
matrix times n over 2,
because I'm going
down m over 2 rows,
and I've got to go
down the number of rows
of the outer matrix.
And then M 1, 1 is the
same as the 2 there.
So here's the-- in general, for
row and column being 0 and 1,
in some sense, this
is a general formula
that matches up with that, where
I plug in 0 1 for each one.
And now here's my code.
And I just want to point
out a couple of things,
and then we'll quit
and I'll let you
take a look at the rest
of this on your own.
Here's my divide and
conquer matrix multiply.
I use restrict.
Everybody familiar
with restrict?
It says, don't tell the
compiler these things
you can assume are not aliased,
so that when you change one,
you're not changing another.
That lets the compiler
produce better code.
And then the row sizes are
going to be n sub c, n sub a,
and n sub b.
And then the matrices that
we're taking them out of,
those are the sizes
of the sub-matrix.
The outer matrix is going to
have size n by n, for which--
when I have my
recursion, I want to talk
about sub-matrices that
are embedded in this larger
outside matrix.
Here is a great
piece of bit tricks.
This says, n is a power of 2.
So go back and remind yourself
of what the bit tricks are,
but that's a clever bit trick
to say that n is a power of 2.
Very quick.
And so take a look at that.
And then we're going to coarsen
leaves with a base case.
The base case just goes
through and solves the problem
for small n, just with a
typical triply-nested loop.
And what we're going to do
is allocate a temporary n
by n array, and then we're going
to define the temporary array
to having underlying row size n.
And then here is this fabulous
macro that makes all the index
calculations easy.
It uses the sharp
sharp operator,
which pastes together tokens,
so that I can paste n sub c.
When I pass r and c, it passes--
whatever value I pass for
that, it pastes it together.
So it allows me to do
the indexing of the--
and have the right thing, so
that for each of these address
calculations, I'm able to
do them by just saying x of,
and just give the
formulas these.
Otherwise, you'd be driven
nuts by the formula.
So take a look at that macro,
because that may help you
in some of your other things.
And then I sync,
and then add it up.
And the addition
is just going to be
a doubly-nested parallel
addition, and then I free it.
So what I would like you to
do is go home and take a look
at the analysis of this.
And it turns out this has way
more panels than you need,
and if you reduce the
amount of parallelism,
you get much better performance.
And there's several
other algorithms
I put in there as well.
so I'll try to get
this posted tonight.
Thanks very much.